Celine Dion is a message for Drake don't
tattoo my face on your body this started
with Drake mentioned the idea to Celine
when they met backstage the Billboard
Music Core is in 2017 yeah so that was
like two years ago Celine sat down with
our heart Radio Canada yesterday when
they brought up Drake's idea again Slean
warned Drake about the downside of aging
please drink I love you very much can I
tell you something don't do that you can
write me love letters you can send me
autographs for my kids you can come and
visit I can have you home for lunch or
dinner we can go for a drink we can sing
together whatever you want to do I can
talk to your mother whatever you want
but please I mean this this is not the
money maker over here but the thing that
I want to say to you is that all of us
here we are going forward in life and
I've always been very thin and as time
goes as you go old are you - when time
comes my face will go long grrrrrr and
it will go not pretty or so please don't
tattoo if you do it just do a fake one
so you can change your mind if it's
Nicole one day Celine another day
Barbara at the time Barbara well who is
it a coal that's a set of Vera - who
would Nicole be barbers are obviously
Barbra Streisand just doesn't the coal I
don't know who she is Nicole Kidman yeah
that's something the coal I can think if
I can't think of any singer that is
Nicole or maybe she's just thrown out
names we just got that that remember
that Beatles tattoo
see that Snoopy has no room for sleep
black thing putting anybody's face on
your body like yeah things are gonna
happen to it over the years those things
progressed that's where kind of motion
like down here yeah so it might be okay
there she is talking like a mom with no
tattoos because my momma said the exact
same thing to me about my tattoos and
he's somebody who has tattoos that
doesn't care if you start getting a lot
of tattoos you don't care because you
know what my tattoos are gonna look old
and wrinkly when I'm old and wrinkly
because all of me is gonna be old and
wrinkly like it's not like tattoos are
going they don't accelerate the wrinkly
process yeah Jonas's that's weird
tennis just as I grew sir don't do it
kate says Selena and Drake together is
like Canada's wet dream yeah it kind of
is if they ever do duet I think Canada
would likely lose hotly I fully agree a
super poppy army track
we're just whales yeah I think it'd work
I'd love to see that but yeah there's
someone saying yeah Amy so she's still
funny I love her oh there is nobody
better this girl there's nobody better I
know I said the same thing about Cody
Lee and JLo there's nobody better that's
solidify